Alley is on the line in Kansas hi Ali
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you for taking my call sure what's up
yeah so my husband and I are young
couple were 23 and we have a
one-year-old daughter were also a
military family so before being a
stay-at-home mom I was military service
member as well so we were working on
double income so we had no debt tire but
now that I'm a stay-at-home mom and he's
the sole provider he still stuck on just
focusing on his own like that his own
priorities rather than the family and
our own debt and together as a couple so
I don't know how to get him kind of
working with me to pay off both of our
debt and not just his okay well thank
you for your service and thank you to
him for his service as well
I think the thing is this the the old
marriage vows say for richer for poorer
in sickness and in health
unto thee are old my worldly goods I
pledge I'm going to take care of you
you're gonna take care of me because we
are now one we are no longer two
individuals that was the the message of
those marriage vows the reason for that
message is is that that's the healthiest
way from a mental health perspective a
relational perspective a spiritual
perspective to have a good marriage is
to be is to be unified to be of one mind
and the interesting thing is you can be
individuals while still being of one
mind to be unified and so on and then
the the data in the financial world
plays out to verify that in that we find
almost no one building wealth over a
long period of time where their spouse
and them are not on the same page
whether or not unified and so might say
that to him you know when we got married
I promise to give you chicken
soup if you had the flu and you promised
to take care of me and I promise to take
care of you we are not a joint venture
we are now a couple coupled together we
are one and I need you to be my man he's
a manly man he's a military guy I need
you to be my man and walked beside me
with me and I will do my part you will
do your part and we will be together in
this and but we're not a joint venture
if you wanted to be a joint venture we
shouldn't have gotten married mm-hmm if
he wanted to be separate
we shouldn't have been together so when
you say that kind of stuff time what was
it what's he gonna say he kind of he's
passive with it so he just wants to
focus on what yeah so don't so you don't
learn to be passive I'm not yeah okay
now passive is not gonna be okay with me
I'm not okay with passion I'm not okay
with you nodding your head and then
doing something else this is me and you
talking about our relationship it's
something I talking about our marriage
and we're gonna have some real clear
conversations about it air because what
you're describing is something and you
may need to sit down with a pastor the
chaplain you may need to sit down with a
good marriage counselor it won't hurt
anything in your young marriage to get
some guidance but what you're describing
is a young man who got married and
didn't think about that what all that
meant when he got married he just
thought he was gonna have ready access
to sex yeah I've talked to him about
getting counseling and he's not for that
as well go go without him then mm-hmm
and go see a counselor okay and get some
help because this is not going to end
well the trajectory that it's on is not
heading in a positive thing it's not
like it's gonna hit the wall and blow up
next week I'm not trying to be
melodramatic but I've met you ten years
from now when you're 33 right
before you file divorce because you put
up with this crap for ten years and it's
gotten worse instead of better yeah
because everything is growing or dying
it's either gonna start healing and
these issues are going to start being
dealt with gradually over them is not
perfect God knows when Sharon Ramsey was
married to a 23 year old Dave you
wouldn't want it to be her okay I made
your husband look like a freakin saint
so um you know and so you know you can
have little patience with the young man
and you guys are going to grow up
together you're both as you said a young
couple with a baby and so just you know
push on it push on it push on it read
books about marriage learn about it but
this is a relationship breakdown it's
not a financial breakdown when you can't
work together on anything because this
is going to translate to raising kids
it's going to translate when the car is
broken down it's going to translate to
like you know I take out the garbage I'm
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and I take the garbage out you know it
translates into your marriage what do
you do you know I mean I can hire
somebody that all the time and we
actually have somebody helps us with
most of that stuff but if it if Sharon
needs that to go to the curb in one of
those little wheeled trash cans my
little butt is hauling it down there
it's 60 years old after 38 years of
marriage so there's stuff like this you
just learn to do for each other as an
act of love as an act of service in the
process you all serve your country
because you love your country
so serve each other because you love
each other
and that's what I would tell you to do
but your husband's not a bad guy he's
just making the mistake that most people
make and most people don't win at
marriage and money that's why the number
one cause a divorce in North America
today's money fights and money problems